- Do you have any favorite traditions
like for Christmas that
you do with your families
or anything?
- Yeah, I do.
It's a little offbeat.
- Can't wait, love.
- Well off center,
but it's a tradition in our family
and I think it comes from their traditions
that they brought to America from Peru.
It's a little crazy.
- [Kelly] So Excited]
- What you do
is you take a napkin
and you tuck it behind
the person who's playing,
you tuck it in their
pants like a little tail,
like a little tail.
Then you light it on fire
(crowd laughing)
and you play a song
and they have to shake their butt
and put out the fire
before the song is over
or else, well before
their pants catch on fire.
(crowd laughing)
- Before it leaves a scar.
- [Female Guest] Yeah.
- What?
(crowd laughing)
How, wait, what is this?
Is this a tradition?
Are they running from,
are you escaping a,
like what's?
- It's all in fun spirit.
It's all fun-spirited.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah, it's not menacing at all.
But basically if you don't know how
to shake your butt you can't play.
- You know what?
I'm in 'cause mama can
shake a tail feather,
so I'm good.
I'm in, wait, do you have any ones
that might put you in the ER?
- I mean,
(crowd laughing)
I'm Irish Catholic so like guilt I guess.
(clapping)
- Oh my God.